IT IS NOW TIME TO PLAY DADDY
LIKE, DADDY LIKE.
DAD: TO SOME, HE'S THE GUY WHO
TAUGHT YOU HOW TO SHAVE.
TO OTHERS, HE'S THE GUY WHO
NEVER RETURNED FROM BUYING
A PACK OF CIGARETTES EIGHT YEARS
AGO.
LITTLE TOO CLOSE TO HOME FOR
SOME PEOPLE HERE.
THE INSTAGRAM ACCOUNT FASHIONED
DADS UNDERSCORE COLLECTS
EXQUISITE PHOTOS OF PROUD POPPAS
IN ALL THEIR PATERNAL GLORY.
I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SOME HIP DADS
FROM THE FASHION DADS INSTAGRAM
AND FOR 250 POINTS, I WANT TO
YOU TELL ME WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING AS THE PICTURE WAS BEING
TAKEN.
FIRST UP, THIS CUDDLEY
CARETAKER.
LET'S SEE WHAT IS HE SAYING.
GRACE
>> WE BOTH LIKE TO [BLEEP] IN
THE YARD.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
HODGMAN.
>> EYES FOR NIPPLES, SON. EYES
FOR NIPPLES.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
THE DOG IS SO EMBARRASSED BY
THIS.
>> BECAUSE HE DOESN'T HAVE A
SHIRT OF THE GUY.
>> HE THINKS, HE THINKS --
>> CHRIS: THAT WOULD BE AMAZING.
>> THAT DOG THINKS HE'S
SKINNED A GIANT DOG'S FACE TO
MAKE THIS.
>> CHRIS: NEXT ONE, THIS
HANDSOME HANDYMAN.
YES, PAUL F.
>> WHAT'S SAY WE TALK ABOUT
CHEM TRAILS OVER A GLASS OF
HOMEMADE CANTELOPE WINE?
>> CHRIS: POINTS, POINTS.
>> CHEMTRAILS. RESPECT,
RESPECT, PAUL.
>> CHRIS: GRACE.
>> WELL, YOU WEREN'T GOING
TO MURDER YOURSELF, WERE YOU?
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
THIS PUFF DADDY.
HODGMAN.
>> [BLEEP] WALLPAPER, RIGHT?
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
>> [BLEEP] CRAZY.
>> CHRIS: I THINK HE'S GOT TO
FIND OUT WHERE MORTY McFLY GOT
THAT GREAT SPORTS ALMANAC.
(APPLAUSE)